welcome to the National Press Club my
name is Judy Pomerance and it's my great
pleasure to be here to introduce and
welcome our guest today Dominick Dunne
who's here to talk about his new book
entitled justice crimes trials and
punishments just a couple of logistical
things before we begin first of all
copies of the book are available right
outside the door and each sale does
benefit the National Press Club library
mr. Dunne will be signing books at the
end of his remarks and at the end of the
Q&A so you might want to pick up a book
at some point between now and then so
you can have it signed also videotapes
of today's event will be for sale
through the National Press Club website
wwp RS org also before we begin I just
want to make an announcement that on
Wednesday August 15 the next event in
our summer of authors will be a visit by
Steven Ambrose who will be here to
discuss his latest book the wild blue
yonder and just to let you in on how
we're going to proceed today mr. Don
will speak for about 20 to 30 minutes
we'll then take questions and the book
signing will follow from there now when
we do the Q&A session you'll see that we
have two mics set up on either side of
the room everyone in question would
greatly appreciate it if you would use
those mics because we are having this
event taped by a number of outlets so
with that I think I'll go ahead and
begin or one other logistical request if
everyone would please turn off their
beepers and cell phones that would be
greatly appreciated and now I will
introduce our speaker I'm sure this is a
man who needs little introduction I
couldn't help noticing as I sat at the
table that Dominick Dunne clearly knows
more people in Washington than I do and
I live here pretty much everyone here in
the room has come up and greeted him
nonetheless I'm going to tell you
something about him one thing that you
maybe don't know is that
he had his start doing among other
things being a stage manager for the
Howdy Doody show now that's my personal
favorite aspect of his resume and
despite that start or perhaps because of
that start he has of course gone on to
become what he is today which is the
chronicler of the lives of the rich and
famous as a contributing editor to
Vanity Fair magazine since 1984 he's
written about some of the world's most
high-profile individuals from Imelda
Marcos and Queen Noor of Jordan who was
here at the Press Club recently - Mabel
Robert Mapplethorpe and Elizabeth Taylor
and of course merrily dropping scores of
names as he goes along he has written
several best-selling novels which of
most of which have been made into
television miniseries including feel
free to correct me I'm including another
city not my own as seasoned in purgatory
an inconvenient woman people like us and
the two mrs. Granville's any of which I
can actually recommend for your summer
reading but Dominick Dunne has also
published a photo memoir which I believe
I saw for sale outside as well and three
collections of essays nonfiction essays
the latest of which he's here to talk
about today his new book again entitled
justice crimes trials and punishments is
a compilation of compelling essays on
criminal cases involving high-profile
individuals now I'd like to read you
just a short excerpt from the Kirkus
Reviews comment on his new book the
kyrgyz review describes mr. Dunn's
essays as quote surging reports on high
society murder cases featuring some of
the most simi and venal behavior this
side of Gomorrah just pretty yeah pretty
irresistible right there making no
pretense I continued quoting making no
pretense of balance mr. Dunn is
scrupulously honest in his reporting and
thorough he also moves at a good clip
pulling readers along as though a hand
had class
sleeve mr. don has a knack for capturing
the air of unreality that bathes these
trials unquote again that's the Kirkus
review mr. Don takes as his theme in
each of the essays the peculiar
intersection were Fame money and violent
crime converge in his description and
analysis of cases involving such
characters as the Menendez brothers OJ
Simpson and Klaus von Bulow he gives the
reader not only the facts but the
context of the crimes in a feel for the
individuals involved we begin to
understand that both the victims and the
perpetrators are quite simply people and
that they're motivated ultimately by the
kind of good and evil instincts that
govern all of us with that I would like
you to please welcome mr. Dominick Dunne
thank you very much I'm always touched
by introductions and it always reminds
me of something that happened to me a
few years back I got a call from channel
13 PBS and they were having an auction
and they wanted to auction me off for
dinner and at the côte Basque restaurant
and yeah of course I agreed and in the
in the auction I went for a lot of money
and so the night came for the the
meeting and I went to the côte Basque Oh
mister dunne yes SS has been taken to
the nice table best table and a few
minutes later the captain came up and he
said your guests are here and so up came
this very nice-looking couple and he was
called Steve and she was called Regina
and hi hi hi sit sit have a drink or two
drink to all this and I happen to be
very good at dinner table chat I just
know how to do it you know and I
couldn't get to first base with Steve
and Regina I mean just nothing to happen
and so finally Regina said to me look we
have something to tell you and I said
what's that and she said we don't know
who the hell you are
and so I said well then what did you bid
on me for and she said we always wanted
to come to this restaurant and you came
with the deal anyway in case there's any
Steven Regina's in the audience today I
thought I just might read you a little
bit from the introduction to the book
and won't read the whole thing just a
little bit to fill you in
I didn't start writing until I was 50
years old although an observers I had
been observing for 40 of those 50 years
my career in television and movies in
Hollywood had come to a permanent halt
the thought of writing had been lurking
within me for some time but I didn't
actually begin until I finally removed
myself from the glamorous world in which
I no longer belonged to a rope one-room
cabin in the Cascade Mountains of Oregon
there I began my second career as a
writer and a recorder of the social
history of the time the plot of that
first book has been played out in front
of me
the year before I left Hollywood the
gossip of the set in which I had once
moved centered around the head of
Columbia Studios David Begelman who
rumor had it had forged a check for
$10,000 in the name of Cliff Robertson
an Academy award-winning actor barely a
word of that scandal appeared in the Los
Angeles Times powerful people saw to
that
the wagons closed in to protect one of
their own I was watching it first
and as it was happening I became
obsessed with the story as I was out of
work I had plenty of time to feed my
obsession and i gossiped about it
non-stop on the telephone trying to get
the story into wider circulation I knew
all the players in it and their wives
agents secretaries and and two occasions
the mistresses by sheer happenstance in
the sort of coincidental meeting that is
a signature of my life a man I did not
know recognize me in the Polo Lounge of
the Beverly Hills Hotel I was having
lunch there with my agent who was
telling me I was all washed up which I
already knew I was not remotely famous
so it was not that sort of recognition
it developed that one of my brothers had
been in this man's class at Georgetown
University and he recognized the family
resemblance he turned out to be a
reporter from the Washington Post and
what he had been sent out to cover was
the long suppressed forgery story that
was so gripping to me he told me that
the actress dina merrill the then wife
of cliff robertson had gone to Kay
graham then the publisher of The
Washington Post and said that a cover-up
of the the forgery was going on the
paper sent out the reporter and a
partner to check out the story but no
one would talk to them secretaries would
not put through their calls doors would
not open for them they had not been able
to gather anything of consequence to
bear out Dena Merrill's version of the
story the enormity of the coincidence
that this reporter
and I should meet ultimately turned out
to be a life-changing experience for me
I was like manna from heaven for him and
he was the release I needed for the
story that was bursting inside of me to
be made known the Begelman story was the
epitome of everything I had grown to
hate about Hollywood I knew a great deal
of the information the reporter was
seeking and I willingly shared it
including all the unlisted telephone
numbers he needed I spent a week with
him and his partner driving around with
them watching two investigative
reporters research and then put together
a story it was they who broke the story
nationally and it was thrilling for me
to know that I had played a part in it I
felt a kind of excitement within myself
that I hadn't felt about the movie
industry for a long time I could do what
these guys are doing I thought to myself
and I did
a tragic event 'im have to tell this
part because this had a great deal to do
a tragic event in my personal life
changed me forever in 1982 my only
daughter Dominique was murdered by a
former boyfriend John Sweeney who
stopped her and then strangled her
I had never attended a trial until that
of the man who murdered my daughter in
fact I had been a feather in the breeze
until that cataclysmic event here there
everywhere never sure of who I was or
what I was supposed to be what I
witnessed in that courtroom enraged me
and redirected me the lies that are
tolerated shocked me as did the show
business aspect that has taken over the
justice system
my daughter's killer was costumed I have
in quotes like a sacristans in a
Catholic seminary for a prop he carried
a Bible which he read throughout the
trial in a pious fashion he was
presented as a blue-collar boy who had
fallen in love with a Beverly Hills
Society girl how I hated his lawyer I
learned in that courtroom that the
rights of the victim do not equate with
the rights of the defendant anything can
be said about the dead and much was but
the killer's grave past offenses as a
beater of women were kept from the jury
the testimony of another of his victims
who had been hospitalized as a result of
his acts of violence was inexplicably
ruled inadmissible by the judge the
trial was a travesty there has been a
television documentary about it
the judge had a personal animosity
toward the prosecutor
the jury fell for the Bible reading act
and John Sweeney who has subsequently
changed his name received a sentence of
6 years which was automatically reduced
to 3 he was released from prison after
two and a half how I hated him even as I
knew that hate is not a state in which
to linger my rage needed a release from
the persistent plan and my mind to hire
someone to kill him an obsession I had
for months which is not an uncommon
reaction for the parent of a murdered
child but unlike the killer I would have
ended up in prison for life instead I
wrote about the murder not just about
the facts of the story but about the
emotional upheaval and the permanent
scars my wife my sons and I suffered
during that period the first magazine
article I ever wrote is the story of
that trial it appeared in Vanity Fair in
March 1984 called justice which was used
ironically as it is in the title here
the affirmative action the affirmative
reaction to this to the article made me
realize the power of the written word it
was read in some law schools to show
just how badly a trial could go for the
first time in my life I felt that I was
in step with my destiny
I became fascinated by trials
I became repelled by the kind of defense
attorney who would do anything anything
to win an acquittal for a guilty person
somewhere along the line most likely
because I had had the experience of
murder myself I began to get personally
involved
in the trials I was covering during the
Klaus von bulow trial in Providence
Rhode Island I spent the night at
Clarendon Court the Magnificent Newport
estate of the comatose sunny von Bulow
as the guest of her two children
Princess olive on ours berg and prince
alexander van osburgh who were
prosecution witnesses in the trial a
friend of Sunny's who was a friend of
mine had arranged the introduction ala
and Alex showed me the bedroom where
whatever happened between Klaus and
their mother happened leading to the
perpetual coma in which she remains to
this very day
her Porto's sheets were still on the bed
her Christmas presents from that year
had never been unwrapped I felt guilty
for experiencing such excitement at the
intimacy of the encounter at that moment
I entered the story and became a part of
it bad journalism journalists say so
what I say back things happened to me
and I let them happen and then write
about them later
some of the trials that I have covered
the first one was the trial of a unknown
woman - you called what was her name
Vikki Morgan Vikki Morgan was the
mistress of Alfred Bloomingdale who was
the best friend of President Reagan all
my stories by the way are way up there
with people like that
and she was a kept woman on the skids an
actress/model
who neither acted nor modeled living on
the wrong side of town and an apartment
from which she was about to be evicted
for non-payment of rent amid the half
packed bags and unwatered plants
remnants of a past life bespoke more
affluent times but luxurious oh there
goes that phone and white self Chinese
porcelain dish I just want to just read
you one thing about her here that I have
somewhere Vikki Morgan was a mistress
who led a mistress's life she shopped
and spent while a magazine waited with a
driver to carry her packages she worked
on her tan she took social drugs
she took acting lessons and she went to
the same hairdresser that the wives of
Bloomingdale's friends went to she drove
expensive cars but she never had the
pink slip of ownership
she lived in expensive houses and
fashionable areas but she never had the
deed to a house she heard secrets that
could have made her solvent for life but
sadly for her she couldn't remember most
of what she heard that was the second
trial that I that I attended and it was
she had met in a drug what do you call
those places there what rehab couldn't
think of the word and she in a drug
rehab she'd met a guy who thought she
was a celebrity because she was alfred
Bloomingdale's mistress and alfred died
without leaving her the house the car
all the things he was going to do he had
a heart attack and died and she was
stuck and here she this woman had
nothing she'd had $18,000 a month
tax-free to spend and she spent every
cent of it and the second he died it was
over she was broke she moved in with
this guy whom she met in the rehab who
ran the Xerox machine at the William
Morris talent agency and she was such a
pain in the neck to him ordering him
around in his own apartment that he
ended up by killing her with a baseball
bat and he got life and anyway that was
that I wanted to go up the prison to
talk to him because I felt that maybe
there were other people involved but
sadly he died in prison of AIDS and I
just like to read this about Klaus von
Bulow the problem with Klaus said one of
Klaus von bulow is closest friends at a
Park Avenue dinner party is that he does
not dwell in the palace of truth you see
he's a fake he's always been a fake his
name is a fake his life is a fake he is
a he has created a character that he
plays
Klaus is trompe l'oeil come in come in
said von Bulow expansively as he opened
the door the front door to Helmut Newton
the photographer who had just arrived
from Monte Carlo for the photography
session and me
von bülow was standing in the marble
floor Greenwald guilt mirrored hallway
of the Fifth Avenue apartment of his
multi-millionairess wife whom he had
whom he was accused of twice trying to
kill in the background a very old
Chinese Butler Harvard watching the
master of the house usurp his duties on
that may Sunday of the seventh week of
his second trial the Danish society
figure was dressed in tight blue jeans
and a black leather jacket from the
beginning the Bamboula proceedings legal
and otherwise had had an air of
unreality about them his once beautiful
wife was one of the country's richest
Eris's his stepchildren were a prince
and princess his daughter was a
disinherited teenager his former
mistress was a socialite actress his
current mistress was a thrice-married
Hungarian adventurous who was not the
countess she was often described as
being the maid who testified against him
had once worked for the Krupps and
lurking darkly in the background was a
publicity mad con man bent on destroying
him well I just love characters like
this and I mean I mean some of the
things that happen to me during these
trials are absolutely extraordinary now
Klaus who knew I believed he was guilty
knew it and the trial took place in
Providence and on weekends we all
returned to New York and one weekend
Klaus
well it was really the mistress aundrea
invited me to a lunch that they gave in
her apartment sunnies is the most it was
like something out of a movie and they
had this everything was beautiful the
dishes that silver the things the
thinking everything belonged to sunny
calm
tose sunny in the hospital and the
mistress is acting as the hostess and I
had said that they had Butler's with
white gloves I had written that I
believed that mrs. Reynolds the mistress
was wearing Sunny's jewels and so she
took me into Sunny's bedroom and we were
sitting together on Sonny's bed and
she's shown me all her and all her that
how better her jewels were than Sonny's
jewels and the next day were all back in
court and he's at the defense table I
mean the whole thing that's what I mean
about getting involved in the story and
and I know you're not supposed to do
that but I can't resist it I tell you I
mean I love all this stuff I mean I love
all these details of these of these
lives you know I know I don't have much
time but I could go on and on I don't
know who to get to if I should get to OJ
or the Menendez but everybody always
wants to know about OJ and just let me
just read the Simpson case is like a
great trash novel come to life a mammoth
fireworks display of interracial
marriage love lust lies hate fame wealth
beauty obsession spousal abuse stalking
brokenhearted children the bloodiest of
bloody knife slashing homicides and all
the justice that money can buy that was
of all the cases of theirs and there's a
lot of them of ass Africa I'd love to be
able to talk about that know how much
time I have but you know the prosecution
lost the case more than the defense won
that case the prosecution just did a
rotten job I mean imagine that the
freeway chase which 90 million people
had watched on
was never mentioned during that trial
what is this all about
imagine that al cowlings the guy who
drove the white Bronco in the freeway
chase the closest friend the one I
firmly believe is one of the three
people who helped clean up the mess
afterwards was never brought into the
trial I just don't understand what that
what that means
there was the I mean every person
connected to that case was an utterly
fascinating character Faye Resnick the
so-called best friend of Nicole Brown
Simpson Kato Kaelin I mean in his own
way of utterly fast that who knows more
than he has ever told and before he
cools or I cool I'll probably go first
I'm gonna get it out of him I and anyway
how am i doing is are you getting
nervous huh
okay okay you know what happened in
there was the first lawyer on the case
Robert Shapiro I mean just tell you it
just the circumstances of my life are
such that I have spent my adult life
through Hollywood and everything among
famous people and there is fame as a
fascinating subject to me and there's a
big difference between a Fame of
accomplishment and event Fame event fame
are the people like Kato Kaelin
and Marcia Clark and who get caught up
in it and they think I am
Marcia Clark turned from one of the
nicest people into this arrogant woman
who believed her own publicity she could
never get over the fact she never
realized she never picked up
how disliked she was by the
african-american women on the jury what
I learned in that case is how religious
the middle-aged african-american women
are they're all churchgoers I had never
known that before and Marcia would come
in day after day in the shortest
miniskirts that you've ever seen totally
inappropriate for a courtroom okay to go
to Jason's in but I mean not not to come
to court with and then she would they
were they have sidebars and she would
come out of the sidebars and judge ito's
I will tell you about him too and and
she'd be laughing with Johnnie Cochran
and she looked cheap and she looked like
they imagined Nicole Brown Simpson was
what Robert Shapiro did no Robert
Shapiro it was always on that kind of
second echelon of lawyers in in
Hollywood and socially had never quite
made it and he became famous for being a
Jays lawyer and he was signing
autographs signing autographs and at the
Rose Bowl game they picked him out in
the crowd they flashed his picture up on
the thing and he got a standing ovation
at the Rose Bowl game and at that time
his only thing was he was going to be a
Jays lawyer in the case he did one
brilliant thing before he burned himself
out because of all the play became a
fool over publicity just a fool and but
he hired the three best DNA
experts in America to be on the defense
team and that's dr. Henry Lee and Barry
Scheck Barry Scheck of one of the most
brilliant lawyers in America who knows
more about DNA than anybody else and
Barry sex partner whose name escapes me
and these guys of course they knew I
mean they knew they knew and what they
did was was they kept using the word
contamination contamination
contamination of the evidence and it was
like a mantra and it was like you know
they kept giving this to the jury have
the and the LA police had done a crappy
job I mean there's no two ways over they
were careless they did walk through the
thing they did all these things and you
know of DNA you can throw up in DNA it
doesn't change the fact it doesn't
change the fact that that was owed a
Simpsons DNA there no matter how many
times they said contamination can it was
brilliant what they did I have to hand
them that but but anyway anyway that
case I became so obsessed by that case
that I couldn't I couldn't lose it ever
took me months and months afterwards and
then there's another case and that which
has never gotten the publicity that
should have gotten in the famous DuPont
family in Wilmington outside of
Wilmington the ritzy place outside
Greenville and the son of the house of
the DuPont heiress then the air was a
drug addict and so he goes to one of the
same rehabs falls madly in love with a
heroin addict who was a prostitute only
for drugs and
and who had AIDS so I mean I could
understand how mom didn't want her in
the family I mean that I accept but how
they killed her how her third husband
who had been her gardener what how he
arranged to have this woman killed was
unbelievable unbelievable and so you
know I'm ended up rooting for the poor
old prostitute you know and it was a
horrible horrible story and now the
other one I'm just giving you a little
tips on these but anyway I can't get
into all of them but I wanted to mention
the Martha Moxley Michael Skakel case
which is going to come to trial soon and
I played a big part in that in that case
when I was covering the William Kennedy
Smith rape trial in Palm Beach a rumor
went through the courtroom that Willie
Smith had been in the Skakel house in
1975 on the night of the of Martha
moxley's murder I see you're looking at
your clock and I'll tell this quick and
and it wasn't true by the way it was a
false rumor but it got me back to
Greenwich and I said whatever happened
to that story what what happened to that
story that I totally had forgotten about
it and they said nothing nothing I said
where's the family well the father died
the mother moved away I found out where
the mother was in Annapolis Maryland
mrs. Moxley you've probably all seen her
on TV she's very media savvy she wasn't
back in 1991 when I first met her and
she wouldn't even let me go to her
apartment I met her in a coffee shop at
the Washington Baltimore Airport
whatever that's called and I said to her
why did you leave Greenwich there's
nobody there's nobody working she said I
couldn't look into the Skakel house
every time I looked out the window
that's all I saw and she said I didn't
know who did it but I knew that in that
house they knew so I said you know I've
written a whole bunch of bestsellers and
they're all miniseries I could do
another one on your daughter without
knowing the facts I could do and when
she realized that I too was the parent
of a murdered daughter she said okay
and that book which is called a season
in purgatory reopened this Ardant didn't
really read it put the spotlight back on
again because at heart nobody wants to
see anybody get away with murder I truly
believe that and the whole series of
thing the the father rushed in Skakel
after my book came out hired a private
detective agency in New York called the
Sutton agency and the he wanted the
cloud of suspicion to be removed from
his son Tommy who was the original
suspect and the last person to have been
seen with Martha they worked for three
years they signed confidentiality oaths
they would never disclose anything that
they came up with and in their three
years they found that Michael had
changed his story
and that Michael was in all probability
of the killer and Tommy had helped move
the body rushed in Skakel when they gave
him this report paid the seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars it cost and
paid it and and the report was put in
the back of a file cabinet never to be
opened there was a kid working in their
office who had helped put all these
facts together to give to Skakel kid
just out of the University of Virginia
and and they forgot to ask him to sign
the confidentiality oh there's always
that one wonderful thing that somebody
forgets in all these cases and he stole
it and he'd seen me on TV and he came
and he gave
this red-hot report and i read it and i
gave it first to a detective who had
been on the case from the beginning
thinking he's going to call back in a
day and say Dominic I can't believe I
can't really hurt from him again
no reference ever made to it and I
realized then nothing's going to happen
on this case and just at that time I
mean this is a really amazing
coincidence
a literary agent named Lucien Goldberg
do we who was very shortly to become
famous
as you know what about Linda Tripp call
me and she was the agent for Mark
Fuhrman from the OJ case mark Fuhrman
had Mark Fuhrman whatever we think I
happen to think he's one of the great
detectives of America and she said I
need a project he had written a book
called murder in Brentwood which is very
good book made the list
and I said Lucy and I've got it I've got
this incredible thing so Mark Fuhrman
came and he I gave him all the
information he took on the Greenwich
police he's got this way of getting on
Geraldo and all the shows that you need
to be on he got the thing going he wrote
a book based on the Sutton report and
his own findings that was called murder
in Greenwich I wrote the introduction I
and that book is what brought about the
grand jury after 25 years so I feel very
very good about that now where it is now
is that the the judge I've been to all
the hearings the judge has ruled that
there's enough evidence to go to trial
the judge had he was 15 at the time he's
41 now the judge ruled he should be
tried as an adult he is now having a
court case he wants that he wants to
have that overruled and
so forth so that trial will start in
2002 I of course will be there as I will
be at the trial of the nurse in the in
the death of Edmond Safra the
billionaire banker in Monte Carlo I know
my times up so I can I could dish for
about the next two hours but I know it's
time for Q&A
if anybody has questions you know where
the two mics are and mr. Dunn will take
you in any order he pleases sir hiya
Stephen Schwartz and the Jewish forward
great admirer of your work thank you um
as one reporter to another pretending
nobody's here was that month's offer
murdered in your opinion in my opinion
yes yes I can't tell you by whom though
I mean what do you think he was murdered
I do I do I just think it's to a man who
was a security obsessed as Edmond Safra
was I mean I've never heard of anybody
who was so surrounded by guards and so
forth and of his 12 personal guards all
trained by the Mossad in Israel the fact
that not one was on duty and there's too
many there's too many things that
happened too many things that happened
and the whole interplay between the
Monaco Police and the Monaco Fire
Department is an utter disgrace that
that they they were in there for two
hours two hours with before the the
firemen actually got to theirs there's
something wrong somewhere in that case
yes ma'am thanks for your time today
I've got two quick questions if you were
in charge and could change anything
about our criminal justice system in
this country what would you change so
that the title of your next book called
justice is an ironic yeah that's nice
thank you that's a second related
question and how do you think our
criminal justice system stacks up
against others across the world I think
our criminal justice system does stack
up I think we are the best but about
juries about juries I am very much
against again and only happens in the
kind of trials that people rich people
and I'm not against the rich by the way
I love rich people but
it's just rich people in murder trials
it's different for them and there's this
new breed called jury consultants and
believe me these are highly paid people
and they are whispering in the ear of
the thing that this one because he
turned his shoulder this way means that
the so forth and so forth and a jury
selection I mean I believe in the next
12 names on the list that's what I
believe but it seems to be more and more
common
this thing with jury consultants I'm
very very opposed to that yes do you
think that the media is the real villain
in the piece with the Chandra Levy and
mr. Condit case well I think I don't
blame the media I always makes me mad
when people blame the media I mean they
really do thank God for the media as
when I say and and thank God for us
reporters that's what I say and and the
media wouldn't have pursued this case if
the congressman had been honest from the
very beginning right in the beginning he
told a major lie of omission by failing
to tell the police during his first
interview that his wife was here on the
weekend that she does that Chandra
disappeared I think that's a that's a
major bit of information that just
shouldn't have slipped his mind when he
was and I don't think it's such a big
deal now that he's offered his apartment
after ten weeks if he was a totally
innocent person he should have said yeah
of course come in come in I don't know
who did it but I don't blame the media
for this at all I blame him for this I
mean I blame him for the immediate
attention is what I mean yes do you
think in this offer case that the truth
will ever come out knowing the strength
of the Monegasque I do not think the
story will ever come out this is what I
think is going to happen because I'm
going to go to the trial of the nurse
and
we're never gonna know that story and
what I what I think I mean I'm going to
keep sniffing believe me and it's just
amazing the number of people who come
and want to talk to me and tell me
things and I think probably at the this
male nurse from Columbia Presbyterian
Hospital in the Pediatrics session is
amazing how he got into the story in the
first place how his he found a lost
camera at Columbia Presbyterian Hospital
instead of turning it into lost and
found he had the pictures develops he
knew then which patient it was he called
them he went to their house to return
the camera and the pictures and Edmond
Safra stepdaughter
just happened to be visiting them and
saw this wonderful man and suffer as I
said had Parkinson's he couldn't shave
anymore his hand was shaking she asked
him if he could shave the thing and so
forth and he had been a green beret he
knew how to fix the air conditioning and
they hired him and whether he has had a
role in this mysterious death I don't
know but if it was a role it's about
this big in an overall story and I think
what's going to happen is they'll put
them away for about seven years they'll
probably let them out and three and it
will be over well be paid this I don't
know this it's got something to to watch
it's what it is that it is a far bigger
story than the nurse and Lily Safra her
role I don't know madam I wouldn't dare
say if I did know the Russian it's very
much of today the story it it certainly
is and and you know the whole thing
about about public relations
I mean Lily Safra now is more PR people
working for her telling of her good
works
in in
the money she's giving to this fund and
that fund and the other fund and so
forth and it's all that's how rich
people live I got one another one yes I
want to know whether they're any of the
lawyers or judges you've observed that
you particularly admire or thought did a
good job and also whatever happened to
David bagel Minh David bagel men really
interesting he took a suite in the
Century Plaza towers in Century City ten
blocks from his house he met with his
mistress for an hour he wrote 20 letters
to friends and he shot his brains out
what was the next one lawyers that you
thought you did a good job that you
admire the judges yeah yeah I mean I'll
tell you I'm never gonna commit a murder
but if I did if I got in that kind of
trouble there are a couple of very
honorable people I think judge Roy black
of Miami who represented Willie Smith I
thought he was a wonderful lawyer and I
think Tom Puccio who gets no credit
whatsoever because Dershowitz gets all
the credit for the four class van Bulow
acquittal what Dershowitz did and I'm
not Durst which is also a brilliant
lawyer and I happen to know and like him
but I mean he got the the first verdict
overthrown on appeal he didn't fight the
second case Tom Puccio fought the second
case and I think he is a defense
attorney with ethics also okay that it
thank you all Oh God sure oh this is a
writing question when you're actually
working on a book writing what's your
schedule like what's your day like
well who disciplined yo I'm very
disciplined I mean I really am and I
mean you know it's it's it's a job I
mean you know you don't wait for the
this inspiration thing I mean it's a
mornings are my best time I get up early
I write every day of my life seven days
a week and I mean I'm always working on
something and I have a novel now that
I'm hoping to get finished at some point
but I'm doing a monthly journal diary in
Vanity Fair magazine so I can keep up on
all these cases they're like serials now
do you know what I mean on all the
latest on Safra all the latest son
Robert Blake all the not now Chandra is
coming in next I have two questions
first have you ever lost friends as a
result have I I mean you know the one on
here who doesn't speak to me and also do
you oppose or support the death penalty
I actually do not support the death
penalty I'm a great believer of life
without the possibility of parole I mean
I I don't feel so strongly that I'd
stand outside of prison in the rain with
a candle on the night of the execution I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that but
III do not support the death penalty and
the the Menendez brothers both got life
without the possibility of parole I am
in touch with the Menendez brothers
because I want to go to they're in
separate prisons they'll never see each
other again
and I want to get the true story now I
mean as I wrote about him I called him
Liars which they were I called him brats
which they were and
so forth but you know when you think
what they're about 30 now or 31 they've
got maybe 40 more years of life in this
8 by 10 cell and you think a waste of it
all these handsome kids they had
everything everything I don't know why
they did that but what I don't believe
was the defense that Leslie Abramson
came up with that their father had
sodomized them I don't believe that for
one minute okay who wasn't speaking to
me oh dear I whispered to you later
thank you very very much
thank you very much for your fascinating
remarks and I couldn't help thinking
when you were describing the very
elegant von bulow place settings of the
very elegant gift that is yours that is
the National crust pop mug for those of
you who haven't seen it before
we will be having a book signing now mr.
Dunn will stay where he is so you all
will come to him with your books I guess
if we just kind of line up around from
this side